the main character Jimmy frickin Butler
as my good friend Kevin hartler likes to
call him let's go let's go
Kevin and Reggie have coined the term
Jimmy freaking Butler from the call in
the win game one you did it again you're
the most clutch team in the league
certainly as broadcasters we can't
describe why can you help me describe
why we got some dogs and I love it I
love every bit of it guys never quit we
never give up we love playing with one
another and we got so much faith and uh
and Trust in one another so that's what
happens you gotta tell me what was going
on between you and Grant Williams uh
some healthy competition hang a lot to
you healthy competition and I love it
I'm always here to compete um I like to
talk at times
um as long as we get the win I'm good
with it though that started the 18-4 Run
what else fueled that amazing run that
gave you the lead some shot making
um everybody was making sure I had the
ball shooting good wins shooting bad
ones but making sure that we get a shot
on goal I mean we got some stops we got
some stops we won the game we'll see in
Miami oh yeah
what do you think what do you think well
listen a lot of people are going to
think it's over but Boston's been alive
better on the road than they have at
home and remember last year's Eastern
Conference Finals the road team won five
out of seven yeah but there's a lot of
faith growing in that heat locker room
led by the guy who was just speaking
with Ali it's going to be a long road
for the Celtics